hey everybody time once again for
another movie you retrospective going
back to the 1990s yeah this is actually
this is our first Terry Gilliam movie
yet yeah 12 monkeys swell monkey and he
also did Brazil which is another good
movie we have to do Brazil I also would
like to do Time Bandits at some stage
because I think I saw another two
million times when I was a kid so yeah
we'll eventually get her but this is our
first Terry Gilliam movie so like I said
doing twelve Monkeys today you have a
mindfuck of a sci-fi movie if you have
yet seen it we're gonna spoil the [ __ ]
out of it so we haven't seen it might
want to check it out and check it out
before you watch this yeah premise is a
guy from the future goes into the past
which is in his past is the 19 what was
at 1996 well yeah they tried to send my
thing to 97 or 99 but no they tried to
set him to 1996 but they [ __ ] up and
they soon to 1990 1990 that's right so
he comes back a couple different times
this Bruce Willis yeah Bruce Willis from
the future is being sent back into the
past to try to find out the source of a
pandemic that wipes out the earth and
mankind is now living on the ground in
cover
sterile or you know not really a sterile
environment but an environment that's
separated from the virus the virus kills
humans but it doesn't kill animals so
it's kind of a evidently a Garden of
Eden on the surface but they can't they
can't surface and Bruce Willis is
playing a guy what was his name again in
the movie mine Cole that's right yeah
Cole is actually a convict serving time
and that's who they're using to complete
these missions and send them back to
like a primitive time travel and pretty
cool flick so if you want to see it go
ahead and you can check out now and then
yeah cuz like I said we're gonna spoil
the plot like maybe talk about some
theories about what crazy-ass time
travel movie because yeah like I said
like many time travel movies it's kind
of like like it kind of hurts your brain
if you think about it yeah it's got
mobius strips and loops and it
you know yeah and honestly this is one
of the few time travel Magna there are
other ones I think people have mentioned
you know primer which was kind of a more
recent one this is kind of one that
adheres to a more I guess deterministic
view of time travel yeah that that it
can't really be changed right so
hopefully you've checked out now if you
want to see this move because we're
getting this one right now yeah shutting
him shut it off okay so because you know
it seems like a lot of time travel
movies move back to the future most
famously and stuff if you go back to the
past and change a little thing then it
will then the future will be wildly
different because of butterfly effect
and whatnot now this kind of takes a
different tack and I think this is
actually if time travel was real this is
probably more like this what it would be
like I didn't know what predated you
would have already happened
yes so your attempt to change it did
failed or your attempts at changing it
happened and you kept you emerged in
that universe already yeah so yeah it's
today because otherwise it would cause
like all sorts of paradox
they've sent him back into the past to
get a pure pure specimen of this
bioweapon if they have the pure specimen
they'll be able to cure it they can't
cure it because it had mutated so many
times in the intercepts worth years that
it's too hard thinking they can't fix it
but they think that they have the
original strain they would be able to
make a cure for it yes so they're
sending him back in time and to try to
find this pure form of the virus but
they don't know where it came from and
Willis Willis is sent back kind of like
a scout and he's been there before
member he took some samples you know
been he you know he brought things back
and got a saw a bear and [ __ ] but it's
pretty neat I guess for I think we're
really kind of the the thing that drives
this movies is the idea of an insane
asylum because as soon as he goes back
he's acting strange evidently they throw
him in a mental hospital and
he's in a [ __ ] insane asylum and for
a minute you don't know what when I
first saw the movie I kind of question
whether or not he was actually crazy and
wasn't a time traveler but maybe he was
an insane guy who believed he was a time
traveler so that's what you were seeing
also well they did leave some ambiguity
on the door because at one stage in the
movie and I mean I know we're kind of
all over the place and I kind of wanted
to go through like point by point okay
but no but what I was saying was at one
stage during the movie when he's hooked
up with his psychiatrist she's played by
madeleine stowe he becomes convinced
that maybe he actually is crazy and that
is not a time traveler yeah you know so
even though I think ultimately he did
really travel through time they do leave
it ambiguous that you could read it that
maybe he really was just a crazy yes but
my take on it after watching it again
recently is that no he's a time traveler
yeah yeah I think so as well yeah
because you know although like I said I
do like ambiguity like that in movies
where it's like oh it could be too many
things happen which that support the
idea that yes he is a time traveler yeah
yeah but this okay so very famously
movie was directed by Terry Gilliam
although he did not write it the
screenplay was actually written by David
and Janet people's David people's wrote
the screenplay or at least an iteration
of the screenplay for Blade Runner so
you know that you're in good hands
it's actually sort of loosely based on a
on a short film from 1962 called La
jetée which was a movie that was you
know if you've gone to film school or
anything like that they usually show it
in film classes it was made out of
completely out of still photographs and
it's kind of a post-apocalyptic Paris
type of thing where people live
underground and stuff so that's where
the idea for twelve Monkeys came from so
what we have in this Bruce Willis
playing Cole like I said the it's set in
2035 and at this stage you know I think
it was five billion people were killed
by the virus
and the people that were left apparently
had natural immunity but they all had to
move underground now Bruce Willis at the
beginning of this his character's name
is Cole he's in prison but I don't think
they ever telling you what he's in
prison for like what did he do the city
he had a bunch of stuff on his record
for violence and sexual assault yeah but
that this futuristic society that he
comes from is not futuristic it's it's
gonna seem funky yeah it's a dystopian
yeah I mean they have the technology to
send somebody back into the past they
can even send messages back into the
past but it looks pretty dirty and
pretty grimy it's not a clean sterile
future yeah kind of like looks like the
Nostromo out of dem alien one yeah it's
all kind of beaten or dark world or was
it called dark city dark city looks like
am I good that's another movie we gotta
do yeah that's kind of a really
underrated flick I feel like a lot of
people haven't seen it but it was
actually pretty cool what am I one of
the better movies in the nineties
because like I said for some reason the
90s that whole decade although this one
was good this came out 90 and they don't
seem to have a really good computer
technology it's just kind of like the
computer technology they show in Brazil
little bits of a bunch of magnifying
glasses and a bunch of old used
television sets taped together you know
that's that's kind of what they're yeah
I think it's been reused and recycled
like Blade Runner
I feel like Terry Gilliam is less
concerned with showing something looking
like modernistic as he is bizarre yeah
he just wants it to look weird and
creepy and yeah settling and pudding
yeah the movie knocks it out of the park
Oh in terms of tone this is really is an
amazing movie and like all the this is
probably probably my favorite acting
performance by Brad Pitt who plays a
crazy person when I saw this in about
20s I thought the movie was kind of slow
and tedious I see it now I loved it you
know I liked it there so this is one of
those movies that you really have to
watch it a bunch of times because
they're so like every single little
detail like relates back to some other
little detail and it's just like this
really intricate like you said it's like
a mobius strip of yeah of story but yeah
so Bruce Willis for some
closed you know crimes or whatever and
he's in prison
and this little cadre of scientists with
their little magnifying glass and
whatever they're telling him that I
guess they chose him because he had a
really good memory yeah I can remember a
bunch of long strings of numbers yeah
and they're like okay well we will give
you a pardon if you go back to 1996 when
the virus was first released on the
earth and if you can find out how it got
released and who released it right now I
think from my understanding of the film
and I've seen it a couple of times but
you know like I said you need really
Phaeton yeah and the reason why I gotta
pay attention
something's happened out of order
because he's not the only one travelling
through time there's other people
traveling through time - yeah and he he
goes through time several different he
travels through time several different
times in the same time frame generally
so weird stuff happens you'll see yeah
and like I said if you think about it
too hard it will give you a thumping
migraine yeah but as I said so he's so
they're gonna send him back now as I
understand it I think the reason that
they're sending him back to 1996 because
they know that was when the virus was
released now they have part of a phone
message from then yeah that is kind of
like messed up but they heard twelve
Monkeys yeah there's something like that
all together
yeah and they did piece it together it
wasn't all yeah but see that's what
kills me see okay yeah this is what
freaks me out is that you find out later
on in the movie that that message was
from him yeah in the future well in the
past in the past he had sent yet right
so it's like so it wasn't really from
him it was from his girlfriend's a
message okay girlfriend to call and she
and she called any kind of wacky answer
what wacky message yeah it's been partly
right it only had yeah a couple of clues
in it but she was joking around she
didn't think that yeah she didn't think
it was working the time travel telephone
message system that the people from the
future
somehow had tapped into the old
landlines of the 90s
well they had a particular voicemail
yeah well account make it actually
people could call yeah the people would
get it but I think what ended up
happening was that because it had been
so long like by the time they got the
message I think the tape would have
decayed somewhat so it wasn't like super
clear because they played him part of
this message which was madeleine stowe
his voice you find out later on and she
you know you find out later why she left
a message in this particular channel
voice and he didn't know who she was at
that time but they're like okay well she
said something like you know the army of
the 12 monkeys they're this is where
their location is they're the ones who
were going to do it yeah you know have a
Merry Christmas or something like that
right so they decided to send him back
to 1996 to see and so for the first like
2/3 of the movie he's trying to find out
this army of the 12 monkeys they're the
ones that are gonna release a virus and
all this other stuff now significantly
he tries to find in 1990 because there's
a Murli by accident well no there though
that's what I was just gonna say I said
significantly yeah
they mean descended because the time
travel apparently in 2035 isn't super
accurate yeah they [ __ ] up so they were
gonna set her in 1996 but he ended up in
1990 instead so in 1990 he starts
talking about hey I need to find the
army of the 12 monkeys which didn't
exist yet yeah and he's like I'm from
the future I have to stop that you know
I have to find this virus or who
releases the virus or whatever and then
so yes to use the phone yeah everything
says I got a I got a call this special
number and the psychiatrist let him call
the number yeah he was gonna call the
people in the future and leave the few
but it rang and some and and signals and
some random
single black mother of like six or kids
in the in the kitchens like what and she
didn't understand he was talking about
yeah because that number had happened
yet up yet and right yeah they didn't
know he was in 1990 yeah and the army of
the 12 monkeys didn't exist yet either
because he's like running around like
looking for they're like goodbye JD or
whatever he he ran into the leader of
the 12 monkeys in the insanity science
and Sam who is played by
now this is why okay this is why I'm
starting to think that this entire movie
is pretty much one entire closed causal
yeah right that now they nightly nested
little package of things yeah that all
have to kind of happen and I don't way
it's a masterpiece yeah and honestly and
he even says a couple times during it
because I think he says to the
psychiatrist at some point you know
she's like oh are you gonna save us all
from the virus or whatever even though
she didn't like believe him yet
he's like I can't you can't change the
past I can't save anybody I just came
back here to get the virus so I can take
it back to the future and we can find a
cure and we can all live on the earth
again I didn't dawn on me the time of
watching the movie at the time but later
on we were talking about it dawned on me
that how is he gonna bring the virus
back well the only way I can think of
even bring the virus back is to catch it
yeah so I guess he was gonna catch it
and then they were gonna cure him and
then he would get his uh pardon right
see I feel like the scientists when they
sent him back I don't think they had
ever had any intention I think they just
wanted him to find the person that
released it and then the scientist was
gonna take care of the [ __ ] okay you
know what I mean good because I because
I remember him saying that he's supposed
to bring a sample of it back yeah I
don't remember if he said that in the
movie but uh maybe I just imagined that
well okay but spoiler alert so he's like
looking for the army of the twelve
Monkeys okay so not only did them
[ __ ] up and sending him back to 1990
and him meeting Brad Pitt in the insane
asylum that actually gave Brad Pitt the
idea for forming the army of the twelve
Monkeys you know what I mean later on so
he so it was his idea Brad Pitt got it
from what's-his-name
right yeah which brat which you know
which Cole didn't realize at the time
and then later on you find out that the
army of the twelve Monkeys was not even
the ones responsible for releasing the
virus
that evolved though they work on women
no they weren't that's right they
weren't they didn't have anything to do
with anything but they all they have you
Ana sized about that though remember a
little bit because um he brought uh
Bruce Cole brought up the idea of the 12
monkeys and then using a virus to wipe
out the earth and remember that he kind
of oh yeah that's a good idea remember
yeah and and they started good but it
turned out in the end he was the one
that did it no another guy did well and
I don't think they had any intention of
doing anything like that um the other
people that were in the army of the 12
monkeys they were just like animal
rights activist
I just wanted to release animals from
zoos and stuff they said later on that
Brad Pitt had started talking about like
wiping people off the earth and
everything but they thought he was crazy
oh but I but at the end when they're
doing their big thing and he kidnaps his
dad who's like the head of the viral the
biology lab right and all they were
gonna do was release all these animals
right weren't gonna release the virus
yeah it was a fake out you thought they
were gonna release that virus because he
was talking he was going to yeah they
actually just released all that Hammond
it was like yeah it was like a red hair
and then you turn out and then it turned
out that yeah they would he and his dad
were involved but there was a third guy
that worked he was the assistant system
at the lab and he was the one that
released it and here's another thing so
actually finding the army of the third
monkeys or the students what would I say
third third monkey the army of the 12
monkeys actually did lead to finding who
did it in a way almost sort of yeah
almost
I should note too that I think and that
maybe this is just my reading of the
film but the assistant who does
ultimately end up releasing the virus on
earth I think he also got the idea from
indirectly from Bruce Willis cuz check
it he goes back Bruce Willis is sent
back to 1990 gives Brad Pitt the idea
about the thing in the asylum or
whatever now there is also a thing where
he accidentally gets back sent back into
a trench in World War
and he was shot in the leg yeah now he
still has the bullet in his leg from
World War one when he comes back and
talks to his psychiatrist in 1996 which
is one of the things that makes her
start to believe that he actually is a
time traveler yeah
now what ended up happening was that
because she had talked to him in 1990 in
the insane asylum and then she ended up
seeing a picture of the guy in the
trench from World War one and then she
saw Bruce Willis in the photograph and
so in the ensuing six years Bruce Willis
dude yeah in the ensuing six years she
started to think hey maybe there's
something to this and she had written a
book written a book about it about
people that had like the cassandra'
complex where they could see the future
but they were like cursed was like no
one believing them yeah so she wrote a
book about that and you see the
redheaded guy yeah and her book signing
and he starts like weirding out about
yeah maybe we should wipe everybody off
there's because we're [ __ ] it all up
and then she's like yeah whatever bro
then you start looking at this movie in
a way in this way did the pandemic
happen because they said Bruce Willis
into the past see that's what I'm kind
of wondering and yeah that's a no that's
what I'm saying had they not said it in
him to stop the pandemic - pandemic
never would have happened because but
because the pandemic happened you had to
send Bruce Willis into the it was that's
what he that's the problem it's a
closely that's the problem and the thing
about it is that I'm not sure how aware
they are because I was reading something
about this and I'm just like oh my god
my head's starting to hurt but so
there's this whole thing like Bruce
Willis during the whole movie he has
these dreams about being a kid in the
airport and seeing a guy get shot and
killed in the airport now it turns out
later on in the movie that that's older
him
yeah he's seeing himself he's seeing
himself as the future yeah killed while
he's chasing after the guy with the
virus yeah so I feel like there's
nothing that could have been done to
alter anything yeah and another guy
comes from the future meets up with them
in the
bathroom at the airport before the you
know because he's tracking down the guy
who's got the virus and gives him a gun
from the 1800s yeah yeah it was a LeMat
revolver it's hard to find now and he
tells him he says you can be a hero
you can if you you know if you kill him
you'll stop the pandemic and he tried
but that really doesn't make sense I
mean but see I think that was destined
to happen right you couldn't stop him
because it had already happened they
told him he couldn't change Bruce Willis
got shot because he had a gun yeah and
then he got shot because he had a gun
and he saw advantage see guess so that
guy had to come and give him a gun I go
hey shoot that guy but then the cops see
or smell us with the gun and they don't
see the other guy and they shoot that
guy yeah so I don't think there is any
way like I said it's a closed causal
loop it's causing itself yeah it's like
a mobius strip and you can't get out of
it whether I mean I guess that you know
the mission okay now is the mission
successful or not because there's a
scene at the end like now the guy the
virus releasing dude the red headed dude
he releases the virus which is just in
these vials it's odorless colorless it's
just a gas so he's going through the
security and the guys like what's in all
these vials he's just like oh release
and then he opens it and he's like hey
you take a sniff nothing in here so he
released it in the airport and when he
says where what his itinerary is if you
paid attention earlier in the movie that
was the order that the virus had you
know yeah the cities that the virus had
taken he starts flying around and taking
it all over the world so you know that
he's like you know the guy that's doing
it now so he's already released it in
the airport which I think it's in
Philadelphia right yeah I think it was I
think it was Philadelphia and um so he
gets on the plane and then the very last
scene of the movie is him sitting on the
plane with this with the [ __ ] with the
vials and everything and like I said
it's already been released in the
airport at this point and then one of
the scientists from the future that sent
Bruce Willis back to the past in 2000
five she is sitting next to him on the
plane and she shakes his hand and says
something about Oh air port shootings
and stuff and something about human
extinction and then he asked her hey
what are you doing she says I'm in
insurance so I think that what they're
saying is that now that they know who
did the virus she came back to X to get
the virus to contract it yeah so she
could go back to the future and they
would have a pure strain of it right out
of the vial right now it's it's
interesting to note though that Terry
Gilliam the director did not want that
scene at the end because he thought that
it was like a happy ending and he did
not want that he wanted it to end where
you would just it's this whole loop and
they can't get out of it right and they
just have to keep their just like curse
to keep doing it over and over again
like it's a deterministic universe but I
guess that the studio were like well
can't you just like tack a little
hopeful ending like maybe they'll cure
it in the future at least cuz like I
said they couldn't do anything about in
the past it was gonna happen regardless
because it had already happened right
but so I think that you're meant to
think from that last scene that she was
gonna get the virus and then go back to
the future and go hey here it is and
they work it makes sense it makes sense
though that the mission would eventually
succeed because they were in the future
with a time machine and a limited amount
of people they could just keep sending
people back into the past until they got
it that's the thing about a time machine
you get all the time to get all the time
they were sending people back to him and
they weren't and they sent him back
several different times in different
places so eventually with enough people
and enough attempts you would that you
in figured out you figured out yeah I
think maybe putting that ending kind of
does make sense yeah I didn't see that
because let's say the mission fails and
it doesn't have that ending all right
they wouldn't have stopped in the future
right they would have said well what do
we do next
we got Time Machine and get thousands of
prisoners yes I'm saying you go back
we'll just send it back and try it yeah
so it makes sense that they would just
want to try it again and then pretty
soon
and really at several points during the
movie you're pretty much thinking that
other people have come back from the
future and are stuck in 1990 or 99 into
them yeah because he keeps running into
people that said hey you're one of us or
like that homeless guy that said I
pulled out my teeth so they can't track
me he knew like yeah he knew who he was
and some of the prisoners defect and
pulled their teeth out and escaped into
the past so they couldn't yeah so so the
implication may be that they've been
sending people back and they messed up
or you know or they got stuck there cuz
at least a dozen of them that they lost
track of you I would think - yeah based
on what the show so you know I wonder
how that like fits into the whole thing
close it because like I said I was I was
just watching like a video on io9 where
the person was like they they were kind
of theorizing that the scientists
actually it was either that the virus
was released because they sent Bruce
Willis back in time or they actually
sent him back in time to ensure that the
virus was released because that's what
they wanted that they didn't really want
to know why yeah it looked like they
were trying to cure it to me it did yeah
I think them sending him back even
though he wasn't the first one he was
just one of the many that they said back
he was the one that caused it he
happened to go to it end up in an insane
asylum with a crazy [ __ ] whose
dad ran that damn virus Institute yeah
and through that connection they heard
about his idea the 12 monkeys and the
bio weapon which gotten crazy assistant
interested in that idea and Bruce
Willis's psychologist who was right in
the books about it yeah because if you
realize you taste they inspired her
realizing that this book that she's
writing is about him and then bats about
him releasing the virus yeah so
eventually they sent back the wrong dude
that was bird Bruce Willis he was he was
the one that causes a series of events
to make it happen
doesn't make it crazy this is gonna be
Bob but yeah I do I do think that that
was ter
Gilliam's intention yeah that the the
very fact that Bruce Willis was sent
back in time ostensibly yeah to find a a
pure thing actually he caused it to
ended up causing it to happen right well
not so much the fact that they sent him
to 1996 but the fact that they [ __ ] up
and sent him to 1990 and he ended up in
an insane insane asylum I think that's
that mistake right and also the fact
that they [ __ ] up incentive to world
war 1 for a second and then he got shot
in the leg and because like I said that
was one of the things that convinced his
psychiatrist that he was telling the
truth that he actually did travel
through time so I think that the that
their mistakes actually ended up causing
the entire pandemic but like I said
there was nothing they could do to
prevent it at that point it already
happened so you couldn't change the past
right it's an old movie it doesn't
really to me feel like an old movie at
the time that it came out it was
difficult for me to watch because it was
kind of head of its time the way it was
edited oh yeah I think it's aged very
well it really has it looks great and
like I said I mean well the thing about
Terry Gilliam is that you know like I
said he just not really worried about
making [ __ ] futuristic and I think I've
said on the show a couple of times
before it's like sci-fi is hard to pull
off because if you make it look
quote-unquote futuristic at the time
that you make it then 10 20 years from
now it's gonna look really really
outdated so I think your best bet is to
do something really stylized and that's
what Terry Gilliam does here like I said
it's very like it's used looking as beat
up looking for its kind of steampunk II
like Victorian innocence like city of
lost children kind of look it makes
sense because he's coming from a
post-apocalyptic future
yeah it's dystopian and made up out of
junk yeah you know worse than Blade
Runner yeah basically so it was made you
know the world that you saw was made out
of early 20th century in mid 20th
century Chuck yeah in the 1990s junk
thrown into it too but even the
television sets they had a lot of look
like they were from the 70s yeah I think
that's why I think that's why this
doesn't look like didn't really a movie
from the 1990s maybe the way you know
other you know
maybe other like more modernistic like
sci-fi movies from the 90s
like I don't know Johnny mnemonic or
something like that would look really
outdated this does not to me it does not
look outdated at all no I mean you know
and the fact that it's such a cool
premise and as I said it's sort of um a
time-travel type of movie that they
don't really do a lot of them this way
like I said they don't do like a lot of
pre deterministic you know like you
can't change the past you can't change
which like I said if time travel if we
could ever do time travel that's
probably the way they'll change anything
right because I saw somebody are
somebody talking about this on a on a
comment section about this movie and
they were like you know if if Einstein
is correct and time is actually a
dimension as in like a fourth dimension
then you wouldn't be able to change
anything in the past present or the
future because it's all happening at
once so I think that's kind of like
where this movie is coming from like I
said it's not a thing where oh we'll go
back to the past and change this one
little thing and then the future will be
different it's not like that you know
what would happen is you'd go into the
past you change a few things then you
come back to be exactly the same because
those changes were already and we're all
ready for you left exactly that's
exactly what changed [ __ ] but it won't
change the course of anything yeah and
honestly the fact that you changed
something was already Geordi they're in
there right that was already
predetermined like at the beginning of
the universe so there's absolutely
nothing even if you think you're like oh
I'm gonna do this different thing it's
just it you would have thought you would
have done that every single day and I
think that's where this movie is coming
from that it's just like this endless
which is kind of what makes it it's it's
a weirdly sad movie like if you kind of
know what's going on you know what I
mean it's kind of sad a little bit
nightmarish like if you think about it
too hard because this poor guy even
though he may not be aware of it he's
kind of doomed to like live through the
same thing over and over again like you
see he's the kid in the airport and he's
seeing his adult self get shot and he's
gonna have to do that over and over
again right because he that kid's gonna
grow up well he doesn't he didn't know
that was him though yeah that's true
so I just remembered it yeah that's what
I mean says he was dying he saw a little
kid there they just showed you that the
little kid was him yeah yeah because he
kept like all through the movie he kept
like having these they can't remember it
somebody getting shot in Airport cuz it
was super traumatic like when he yeah it
was him though but he didn't know it was
him that's what I mean the very end he
knew it was him yeah that would suck if
he did know it was him cuz if it like I
said that's what he didn't know in the
in the sense that you know you're
watching the loop happen like as the
audience of the movie but the characters
in the movie are not necessarily aware
of it they think that they have free
will and that they're changing things by
their actions and stuff but I don't but
from our godlike perspective we are
seeing that they're not able to change
anything but that it's a foregone
conclusion you know what I mean yeah so
I think that that's kind of what that
what that movie is coming from so yeah
um this is actually a really really good
movie I feel like it's one of the better
you know better movies in the 90s easily
one of the best sci-fi movies in the 90s
it actually made I think it was Terry
Gilliam's most successful movie made
quite a bit of money because you know
Terry Gilliam's movies are a little
weird and sometimes they're not for all
tastes and whatnot I really like him but
I know a lot of people don't but this
one did pretty well and like I said I
think it made more money than any of his
other ones so you know check it out if
you haven't or you know check it out
again and see if you agree with our
theories know what the hell is going on
in this movie if you can keep your head
from exploding and that will do it for
our latest movie retrospective about
Terry Gilliam is twelve Monkeys remember
if you liked the show like share
subscribe on all your social media and
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the
sidebar where it goes to a PayPal
account if you'd like to give a one-time
donation the PayPal button was actually
not working for a little while but it
has been fixed now so if you went there
and pushed out over like we're nothing
to happen and so it's it's fixed now so
and remember these movie retrospectives
come out every Friday and we also have
thirteen o'clock
name three new movies in the theater
that comes out every Sunday and our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
so check them out we will see you next
time bye